thank you all for coming here today and
thank you mati for inviting me here you
actually took a chance because this is
my first talk at an international
conference and it happens on a very
special weekend to me because I get to
celebrate my birthday with you guys I'll
be 33 tomorrow I was born in a small
town in central Romania on July 8 1985
the name of the town is Reagan he's in
Transylvania close to the mountains it
actually has some strong German heritage
and in that year in 1985 the world was
very different the Berlin Wall was still
in place here in Berlin in Germany and
it separated the East from the West as a
child from the Communist part of Europe
I only got chocolate for celebration my
favorite one was that in red there it
has a bit of a sour taste and we only
got oranges during Christmas what you're
seeing this is people standing in queue
to buy bread and they often went there
to stand in line at 5 or 6 a.m. in the
morning they weren't waiting for the
latest iPhone this is something
different there and I have here a little
joke from that time an old man stops in
the middle of the street looking at his
empty bag confused I can't remember he
says was they going to the market
or was I coming from the market and the
the the orange thing there that's the
label of a very low quality orange juice
that we used to have back then and which
was revived a couple
years ago the apartments in which people
lived in Romanian I think this is true
for most countries in Eastern Europe
were cold and dark often we had no
electricity and we had to leave on food
ratios we only had a kilogram of chicken
every month per person and we had to
limit the way and find ways of finding
food so people who were seen as smart
were the ones that were able to get food
it's totally different how it was how it
is right now but in this culture of
people trying to find food or trying to
find clothes for their children there
were also some computer enthusiasts this
is not a Romanian computer this is a
British computer that was fairly small
it was built around the zilog z80 a cpu
and it used basic how many of you know
the basic computer language awesome
perfect and well technology in the
Eastern Bloc often cloned technology
from Western Europe and people in
Romania cloned the spectrum it it had
also happened in Ukraine in Bulgaria or
Arno in in every country in Russia they
also cloned and there are some stories
with spies going to Western Europe and
the US to technology factories taking
some components bringing them to the
country and talking to engineers who
were able to reverse-engineer them and
build a product that was bulkier because
let me show you something this is a
Romanian computer but the ZX spectrum
the original computer that was used to
make this as half it's way smaller
so anyway there are some stories of
Romanian spies going to Texas
Instruments in the US and bringing
technology and because we were a bit
poor back then
we had to have loans that were less
expensive than the original so we
basically try to find creative solutions
in order to be able to have a computer
industry back then this is me with my
computers at home so the ones with red
blue and yellow are cheap computers this
is the name the blue one is here the red
one there is the one that I donated to
Computer History Museum in the US and
there's also a blue one upstairs which
is fitted inside a telephone case
because they at the factory they used to
have telephone cases and they said well
why not there's also a computer in
Ukraine that's fitted inside an organ
case so the idea was to have a product
that works and this is a very rare
computer that sadly it's not in my
collection the name is Cobra and it has
nothing to do with the reptile Cobra
came comes from computer I brush off
brush Rove is a city in central Romania
fairly close to my hometown and the
funny thing about this computer why this
computer is special is that it will it
featured not only basic but also CPM
this computer was produced in Brasov to
be used in factories and there weren't a
lot of Cobras made back then I would say
that there are there were made less than
a thousand and they were quite pricey
the cost of a cobra computer was half of
the cost of a Romanian car at the time
we had gotcha on me at race with the car
which is similar to Renault 12 only I
would say a bit lower and for a regular
person working having a daily job in
Romania was virtually impossible to buy
such a computer because first of all it
was only used in factories it wasn't
available on the market and second
because of the price so what do you do
when you actually want to have a
computer but you cannot buy a computer
you build one yourself and now when I
was a little girl in my hometown in
Romania in Bucharest the largest city in
the country at politécnica University
the red tiled building there on the hill
there were some people students who were
trying to build computers from nothing
and when I heard about this story I said
well this is actually a good story if
it's true so I went to a former
colleague of mine from the radio station
and asked him well Mihai you have the
right age you were in politécnica back
then in the mid eighties do you know
anything about students building
computers there were probably two or
three of them doing that you happen to
know them and Mihai told me well I used
to build computer there in politécnica
and there weren't two or three there
were two or three dozen students
building so I said well we need to have
lunch
he works fairly close to where I work so
I met him and he told me a couple of
things about his cobra he build it when
he was in high school and he said that
he is somewhere in his apartment on a
cardboard box but he's now moving so I
should wait a little bit until he and
his girlfriend managed to set the
house and then talk to him and I asked
him of course is your Cobra working and
he said well I don't know I haven't
switched it on in a decade or maybe two
this is how his Cobra looks it has
nothing to do with the original when you
compare the pictures because this is not
a Cobra case you wouldn't find cases for
Cobra so each student used whatever they
could
so what's funny is that the Cobra worked
with a tape recorder and cassette tapes
were used as storage medium for
computers back then there was no SSD
magnin this is how the Cobra looks
inside the upper part is where the
keyboard is and you have here the
motherboard the ugly thing there on the
left is the video card but it's not a
proper video card it was built by the
students and there were no two video
cards the same and there on the right is
the z80 chip and I do have the specs of
a cobra so you're going to find some
really cool numbers there it was three
times heavier than the spectrum it has
it had 16 colors so very good okay so as
a student you want to build a cobra how
do you do it easy you have a pack of
Kent
cigarettes and Kent cigarettes were used
as a bartering medium there were more
powerful than money back then in Romania
and also coffee but Kent cigarettes were
just Western goods and they could help
you go a long way this is a story from
The Wall Street Journal from 1984
so um
back then in politécnica University in
the dorm rooms there weren't drug
dealers
there were electronics dealers people
coming to the campus with bags of LEDs
and resistors and selling them to the
student and sometimes you would buy a
bag of electronics but you wouldn't know
how many of them actually work the case
was the least interesting part of the
computer there was some computers fitted
inside wooden boxes or metal boxes and
the funny thing is that the motherboards
were discarded by factories what does
the discarded mean some of them were
sold by employees on the black market
and they were labeled as are no faulty
motherboards they had just a small tiny
issue that a skilled engineer could fix
and one of the dealers was called the
American I tried to find him but I
couldn't
Mihai told me that he knew at that time
that it was an illegal operation that
the police could come but he said that
no student no student had problems with
the police because the police man would
say that maybe it's at some point I need
this guy to build a computer for me so I
think I shouldn't arrest him and what
mattered to them was that although they
did something illegal they really liked
to build something they really liked to
have a very cool project and see that
they are able to do something that in a
way defies the system and I really liked
what Mihai told me the fact that you
could play the game you wanted when you
wanted gave you the illusion of choosing
for yourself choice was regulated
by the state back then in Romania and
people had to do whatever the state told
him to do we only had two hours of TV
program each day and if you were caught
listening to Radio Free Europe well bad
news for you
so Mihai managed to set up his new home
and I asked him about the cardboard box
do you still have it could we maybe try
to see if your Cobra still works or not
and well he said I still have my my
computer let's try to plug it in and see
what happens
but wait he had no charger and he also
thought that he needed an old TV set he
said he will have no problem fixing the
computer as long as he finds the charger
well I did have a charger because you
know that I have some old computers but
I couldn't just hand my charger to Mihai
because as a journalist you want your
characters to struggle
so I said to me hi well is there anyone
you could call well he said well there's
this guy I haven't talked to him in six
or seven or eight years but I could ask
him and maybe he could help this is a
photo
these are not my guys but this is how
the dorm room of Polytechnical
University used to look back then this
is where they built cobras and the guy
that may hike old is marios Illawarra I
met with Olivia in the campus close to
the dorm rooms he had orange juice and
we started talking about the cobras and
he says well I actually built a Cobra
that I sold to be heist father and we
have me heist father only paid me half
the money and he said well I'll bring
the Cobra home I'll plug it in and if it
works I'm going to give you the other
half of the money and this is what they
did and when we high as a child got the
Cobra well he played with it a little
bit and afterwards he decided to look
under the hood and he said well I think
I could do it and he started building
cobras he willed four cobras one for
himself one for his girlfriend at the
time and to Congress for two of his
friends but unlike me hi Edie why are
maintained a small business of building
Cobras he had deals with the dealers and
he was able to buy all the needed parts
for 6000 lei which is about two and a
half of monthly income pay okay but he
sold the Cobras at a higher price still
lower than the official price of the
factory in brush-off and those were some
the best years in his life what did you
do with the money well party okay I
didn't save anything okay smart and what
was amazing about these guys what they
that they kept comparing themselves with
Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak and the
Americans and why I told me what we did
is a scaled-down Romanian version of the
history of Jobs and Wozniak they built
their first computer in a garage and if
you compare them to Apple people you'll
see that Illawarra is some sort of
Johnny eyes because whenever he talked
about the Cobra that he made he said
flawless product perfect line others did
build computers in three days but we
wanted to have a flawless product we
took weeks to build a computer two or
three weeks and nobody complained they
were charmed Romanian computers I
shouldn't be saying this but here I am
Romanian computers are known by their
faulty keyboards there are very few
computers with good keyboards made in
the 80s in Romania and either why I
didn't want to buy regular keys so he
bought keys from mainframe computers how
did he bought them well he he tells me
this is a story the recorder shouldn't
hear okay and he brought those keys he
polished them with a nail file he cut
the excess material and Akili look like
looks like this today right but back
then there were just normal plastic keys
there they didn't have letters typed on
them so on the key people put a small
piece of paper writing the letter and
then a transparent cap was inserted to
hold that
piece of paper Mihai didn't bother he
just glued the paper and that was it and
because of the Cobras a lot of people
started doing connected things there was
a guy who was selling photo papers with
letters for every key to the Cobra
people but anyway I didn't wanted to
work all day because he wanted to party
he had money to party so he thought his
girlfriend to build computers and he had
some creative thing of saving money
because he every part that could be
manufactured was manufactured and he was
really proud of the power supply unit
which he made by folding an aluminium
sheet cut in a t-shape this is the video
card that I was showing you earlier it
was made out of 20 or 30 general-purpose
circuit and it's interesting to talk to
these people about how they felt back
then ey also knows that he was doing
something illegal but actually you
couldn't have a legitimate business back
then in Romania and this is a quote that
I particularly liked even in a communist
society there are entrepreneurs people
who want to risk to make more money than
the regular salary and of course
Illawarra sips his orange juice and
tells me Steve Jobs would have been
proud of us anyway I gave me higher
charger for his laptop but the Cobra
still didn't want to start so it was
time to call that guy who could fix the
unfixable
here's some sort of doctor house for
cobras and his name is Mihai Budaj he
was also having a small business back
then he made five or six Cobras a month
but anyway I says Johnny I have that
they didn't look as good as his but
people know what ditch for the fact that
he could he could find what went wrong
with the Cobra and this is how he do it
he connected a TV set to a circuit and
counted the number of lines that
appeared on the screen if there were
horizontal lines he would multiply that
number by sixteen and four vertical
lines he would multiply the number by 50
this is how he learned the frequency of
a circuit but it says that he
encountered many short circuits on
motherboards and he says that did this
was the pretext to classify them as
faulty and take them out from the
factory and sold them on the black
market at that time in Romania the
regime didn't want people to build
radios or other devices so electronics
were highly overpriced but he says that
comparing himself with Apple he says
that he didn't do much the fact that a
dude from a remote place designed a
thing with 30 integrated circuits
replace a small $10 chip wouldn't amaze
Apple they were cultivating acres of
land while we were caring for a seed in
a town pot
I asked him whether what he did back
then was ok or not because what they did
was illegal and he says that you
wouldn't be able to judge what happened
then with today's moral values because
during communism people who were able to
get more food and more money were seen
as smart people and doing some illegal
things was part of the surviving
mechanism so eventually but each tells
me hi that he should check every single
part of the Cobra so Mihai gets to work
and I keep telling him here's a Linux
guy he is very involved in the
open-source community in Romania he did
the first Linux distribution in Romania
which was based on the rat hat and I
told him well you're actually quite
skilled when it comes to fixing
computers and he said well there's back
then people were more connected and
people who knew how to write code they
also knew how to fix their computer
hardware and software weren't different
things back then and compared to my
Cobra developers today drive Ferraris he
said but when they're Ferrari stop they
call the customer service I can still
grab my screwdriver open the bonnet and
fix it myself
so the Cobra kids did know both hardware
and software many of them buddies
assembled the Cobra code line by line
Mihai says that he knew what every line
does every subroutine and that he
changed the codes to optimize it I knew
whether any bit should be 1 or 0
depending on what was happening so
Moldovan who looks under the hood of
history bond
and he shows me capacitors with both
caps and right electrolyte on top he
replaces them and magic his Cobra
started horizontal blue and yellow lines
appeared on the screen this is a game
manic miner not miner for cryptocurrency
manic miner we didn't have blockchain
and we didn't huddle back then I do have
the game if you're interested after the
Q&A session we could try manic miner but
me heist favorite game was Highway
encounter and after he loaded the game
and just couldn't talk to him he was
captivated and I said well I'm just
going to leave you there thank you so
much for accepting to talk to me in for
sharing this story but wild Cobra kids
were busy building their computers in
the latest part of the 80s which was the
most difficult part for people living
under communism something started to
happen in Berlin people said that the
walls shouldn't be there that people
should be united and that and little by
little communism collapsed in all the
countries in Eastern Europe at some
point in Romania people gathered in the
largest cities it was December 1989 a
Romanian president at that time Nicolae
Ceausescu addressed the crowds and he
told them we will give you a hundred lay
kids go home
but they could a thousand people died in
Romania during the 1989 revolution it
was a touching moment for me two days
ago to visit the Berlin Wall and hear
the names of the people who died there -
who wanted to escape to freedom
Ceausescu was eventually tried and he
was shot on Christmas Day that year but
there were also demonstrations during
that time and on that photo you can read
liberty freedom there and don't shot the
people because the army shot the people
back then more than a thousand people
who died and in Berlin at that time
there was even a protest of solidarity
for the Romanian the Romanians who died
in December now back then I was a small
girl in a small town in central Romania
I was four and a half year the communism
collapsed and this is a relevant photo
of me because I had my best blouse back
then it's you won't be able to see it
but it was pink and I was told to stay
still for this photo because it was
unofficial photo my parents applied for
passport and many people in Romania
after 1989 applied for passports because
freedom meant that they could finally
travel abroad very few of them used
those passports
my parents didn't after communism
collapsed in 1989 a lot of things
happened well the economy imploded a lot
of factories were closed down and
inflation reached a maximum of 256
percent a year
which meant that the price of bread for
instance would grow two or three times
during a single day and back in
politécnica University of Bucharest
there were some students who also wanted
to go on with their lives and to do
their best even though this wasn't a
perfect moment for their youth on that
red tile building they're on the ground
floor there's a door looking like this
it says computer network laughs II
d-o-double one and this is one of the
most mysterious rooms in Romania because
each night when the professor's were at
home in their slippers the cool kids
headed to this computer lab with a heavy
wooden door ready to rock and roll in
this computer lab kids gathered to
target NASA the Pentagon military bases
Lockheed Martin Boeing and other
companies many of them from the US when
I told my friend Egor who's also a
hacker that I'm going to have this
presentation in Berlin and this is going
to be my first presentation he said to
me well in the Eastern European spirit
if you want them to listen to you you
bribe them
so I took inspiration from this photo
and I'm just going to offer you some
Romanian plum brandy during the Q&A
session there for those of you who know
the the right answer for a question so
in order to get to Edie Oh double one
computer lab you would have during the
night you would have to bribe the
doorkeeper wait vodka and at that time
in Romania the Scandic vodka was quite
popular it was inside the tetrapack not
a normal bottle like the milk bottles
and because it was quite squarish and it
had a straw when you attach the straw it
just looked like a Motorola smart phone
telephone sorry so this is why this
particular vodka was called Motorola
vodka the kids who went to video double
one world rebels they were trying to
discover the world just like my parents
did with the password they wanted to see
well what how do people look in the u.s.
what did they do
are they smarter than us and many of the
kids back then grew a long hair and wear
blue jeans and dark t-shirts just like
people's from people from the Western
world the whole rebel culture was the
thing to do back then in the early 90s
if you were a student this is the
computer lab today
II do double one and back then the
computers were lined along the wall and
the center of the room was empty so a
sysadmin standing in the center of the
room would see what every students a
student did on his computer
they had 286 and 386 five
he sees the students from the first year
only had one such PC the students from
the second year had two and so on there
were about of that about a dozen IBM pcs
and there were also six DAC VT terminals
with black and green screen which were
less crowded the university had some
internet connection and it was one of
the few places this computer lab where
students could access the internet
without paying and this is why it was so
important to them and let me introduce
you to one of the best hackers Romania
ever had
his name is Larry but because I cannot
show you a picture of Larry I'm just
using a picture of Larry David Larry was
a thin student long-haired he had black
shirt and blue jeans
and he was the student that used to
upset the Dean it is said that back then
the dean's desk would pile up with faxes
from abroad saying that one of his
students
hacked servers again and the student the
Dean always blamed Larry he knew it was
this metalhead who spent all his nights
in the e do double one computer lab he
used to listen to Slayer anyone here
listens to Slayer oh great thank you
yeah they have some strong lyrics
anti-religion lyrics they often are
quite aggressive in their songs and
rebel and this is why Larry liked them
like all great things on planet Earth
Larry started hacking because of a girl
he met her online he was at a university
in Illinois and they were talking on a
chatroom and at some point larry lost
the connection i didn't know whether she
was still waiting for me or not
and in that frenzy I hacked her
university server to see if she was
still active Larry didn't want to
disappoint the girl the server had a
standard vulnerability easy but Larry
was in a hurry because he had to catch a
train to go to his parents and after the
winter break when he returned to the
University there was a huge scandal and
Dean was furious he learned that Larry
hacked the University of Illinois and
Larry said well at that time I didn't
have the time to delete the logs but
next time I will learn something from
what happened and delete the logs no
matter what just let the train go and
Larry thought that he had to be a better
hacker and he started small by targeting
romanian universities late in the night
when nobody was watching and after he
hacked all the universities and he got a
few complaints through the Dean he
wanted to start a bigger project he
wanted to see how hackable the whole
internet is he hacked organization that
sounded cool such as NASA or the US
Department of Defense's army dot mil and
this was his mission if I some ordinary
Joe from God knows where could hack the
US Army nurse and other such targets
imagine what could s P&R agencies do
they rely on thousands of experts and
just a matter of time until they seize
the opportunity so he wanted to he
doesn't see himself as a hacker but
rather as a new early version of
pentester he was his mission in 1993 to
see how hackable the world is but he
couldn't do everything by himself so he
said let's automate he build his tools
from scratch and he developed a worm his
worm relied on database of
vulnerabilities both known
vulnerabilities and vulnerabilities that
he was able to discover and when his
more worm was installed on a server I
didn't do harm he says it only spread to
other servers reaching new departments
within the organisation or independent
contractors Larry's worm was a bit
better ridden than the Morris worm the
great worm who was also made a few years
earlier to dodge the size of the
Internet and one day Larry tells me that
his worm was able to reach private
contractors in the u.s. armies such as
Boeing Lockheed Martin and various
research labs he was even able to find
some marine Raiders blueprints but he
says he didn't do anything with the
files he found what was I supposed to do
sell them he said well no one day he
tried to hack CERN he was really
passionate about supercomputers and CERN
had great supercomputers so it was
heaven but he was frustrated that he
couldn't hack their main web server
paragraphs were separated by a line of
made out of plus characters and he only
wanted to add a plus character at the
end of that line he didn't want to do
anything intrusive he just wanted to to
prove to himself that he was able to
hack well he actually did manage to hack
this server and he added a plus at the
end of the line but a sysadmin at cern
noticed this and did some investigations
and found out that it was put by someone
from politécnica university of bucharest
at which point the Dean got another fax
from abroad saying that one of his
students had servers again CERN also
said that is great that politécnica has
people interested in security and that
the university should have a safe
environment for testing different attack
scenarios this is what Larry tells me he
says that whenever he found
vulnerabilities he would talk to the SIS
admins and let them know that there is a
way they could fix it and he befriended
a guy from UCLA they were in contact for
more than a year and it's really
important to say at this point that
Romania didn't have legislation banning
computer science or computer hacking
back in the early 90s at some point
legend has it that even Romania's
president at that time your nilly a
school called the politécnica university
to ask the Dean dude what are your guys
doing and also the US Embassy it is said
that they also called politécnica
University - and for some regulation to
stop the kids attacking foreign entities
I've tried to reach out to the US
Embassy in Romania and they said to me
well it was a long time ago we can
neither confirm nor deny what happens
I've also tried to reach out to a former
minion president Johnny Lee s code to
try to confirm this I've also tried to
call a former ladynina but because young
yes was tried for crimes against
humanity he wouldn't reply whenever
students did something wrong
they had a professor that backed them he
would close the lab for the night just
to show that his taking measures but he
told me that the students only wanted to
learn and they didn't want to do
anything bad and this is a fabulous
quote one of the best that I've received
as a journalist if you don't break
things
you won't understand how they are made
so this is why he allowed them to have
Larry worked very hard during those
years and he said that he lived like a
zombie during winter I wouldn't see the
Sun for several weeks in a row and now
we're going to talk about his greatest
hack the Pentagon hack one day his worm
showed him that it was able to access a
server at the Pentagon
so Larry tried manually to access that
server and he was kicked out of the two
or three minutes and then for a week he
tried to find that server going through
different military bases and he was able
finally to find it and he told me this
is where I got my trophy so to speak I
found the file with thousands of
Pentagon employees with names surnames
and phone numbers I've tried to reach
out to the Pentagon to see if this
information is correct or not and their
spokesperson told me well this was
almost 30 years ago I couldn't find
anyone here who was there at a time so I
can neither confirm nor deny Larry says
that he was the only person in the early
90s who ventured abroad but after the
1996 when he was kicked out from the lab
because this
the Dean said well enough is enough
and he banned him from using the
university's computer but there were
other hackers who said this is actually
cool this is actually something we could
do this February on a very cold morning
I met and they're in Bucharest in the
outskirts of Bucharest in college he
took the nickname under after Orson
Scott Card's character the shy but smart
kid who trained to save the world under
what was also a hacker interested in the
rock music he liked to listen to Nirvana
and he liked how Kurt Cobain played the
guitar if you listen to Nirvana how many
people do listen to me right here you
denotes artists act together and it
shows that Cobain was quite creative and
that the fact that he was a self-taught
musician like the character my Ender
became the master of cyber war games he
built his first virus when he was a
sophomore he told me that so every kid
back then in Romania had a computer
virus the and he tried to make it stout
here and more compact he tested using TB
a V and F fraud he is really happy about
his virus because he was he couldn't be
caught by antivirus software back then
and there is virus was quite creative
it booted the computer after four
minutes and 25 seconds because his
birthday was on April 25th and at some
point under became a cyst admin at
university and because he's a shine on
conflictual guy he used it against the
kids who are playing games
not living the shy kids at the computer
to do their homework so it was his way
of helping the other shy kids at the
University this is a better known
viruses the tequila virus from 1991 and
back then viruses did cool things like
displaying the Manor birth fractal they
also played songs and were work right
creative they didn't do harm well some
did but they also did some cool things
and there says that he has never
released his virus in the wild but he
only wanted to learn more about computer
science because II do double one was the
perfect environment to understand how
technology works the best people are
those who spend nights learning like we
did not those who get ethical hacking
certifications these mostly teach
theoretical principle there isn't a lot
of practical information there says
under I've also met vampy Stefan it's of
will kun is another hacker from ET au
double one but unlike the other two
he likes to listen to ac/dc and Mozart
quite a complex personality I would say
he told me that he once spent 36 hours
in a row in the lab but he wouldn't like
to brag about it because there were
students who would spend two or three
days in the lab glued to their computers
vampy told me a lot about IDEO double
one being their connection to Western
Europe and the US because it was very
expensive all to travel that then he
also says that unlike today hackers back
then had common sense and this stopped
them from causing damage to the systems
they gained control over they realized
that nobody is gaining anything from
that and he also says that hackers were
eating
when hackers were smarter than their
professors at university so it was weird
to have that professor come and say
thanks for teaching me things but maybe
you should stop hacking this is a photo
taken by one of bumpy's friends vampy
shaking hands with Linux Torvalds who
went to Romania in 1995 and this photo I
was told white was taken after 13 beers
we were all dreamers some of the dreams
are still alive today vampy tells me one
evening before Christmas I get to meet
Makoto little guy after the the ender
and vampy generation came the makoto
generation they had a talent based chat
system called meet in IDEO double one
and they came there to login and made
girls and I get to spend an evening
having beers with the meat guy little
guy Phil Terry on Dave and zombie and
Phil tells me during this being social
and meeting people was an important part
of the late 90s and that some of the
couples are still together today I've
tried to hook up with one of two girls
on meet Phil tells me but I couldn't I
was too shy I also talked to Terry on
and zombie and I find out that they were
introduced to Eddie Oh double one by two
girls one of which was in a relationship
with a sysadmin
and what this guys did was basically
play games and meet girls and only did
pranks to obsess upset the sysadmin
which is this guy they still hate him
today the sysadmin has an office in the
basement of politécnica university
hysteresis
admin today and students used to make
fun of him they cursed him because
whenever a student did something wrong
he had to step in and banned a student
from the lab on his office door he had
two sheets of paper with the schedule
and the basic instructions for those who
wanted to use the lab and half of the
second piece was empty so students who
hated push castro filled that space with
unorthodox words and then he printed
another piece of paper and he said in
this empty half you can express your
frustrations so nobody ever dared to
write an absurd unorthodox words or so
he says a year ago in a land far far
away in st. Maarten I get to go to a
security conference where I see a
picture of politécnica University of
Bucharest on screen this is the security
analyst summit is the first collapse
conference yearly conference and this
guy here is costing Rio here's one of
the the best experts in from the
security industry in the world and he
also spent some times in IDEO double one
computer lab his passion is to study the
history of malware and to try to find
connections between the past and the
present this is why he calls himself
malware Pauline colleges and at this
conference they showed information new
information on the moonlight maze this
is one of the first major threat actors
and they found the server in the UK the
year before and using information from
that server they were able to connect
them
like mace which was the first major
traductor to the tour law group this is
a russian-speaking actor that was active
up until two or three years ago and they
targeted NASA the Pentagon and other
military targets from back then so they
were basically able to connect the two
entities and during the conference
Christine says something like this IDEO
double one was the home of some of the
most best hackers in the world I've
watched all these people in amazing
he analyzed attack vectors for this
research thanks to what he learned when
he was a student back then and people
from IDEO double one were hacking into
army dot mil and they had root cells on
NASA computers costing would wake up
early in the morning at 5:30 to go to
this computer lab and read what was on
the International Liberation Front to
see if there are new malware samples
he made the rough antivirus which was
acquired by Microsoft and he says this
really cool thing 99% of all the high
profile hacks were just enthusiasts in
the early 90s kidz challenging each
other to see who can access the most
data and only 1% of all the high profile
hacks were government-sponsored today he
says it's the opposite
99% of all the high profile hacks are
government-sponsored
this is Christine and his team and you
can see here vampy little guy and under
in the IDEO double one computer lab a
year ago soon after little guy graduated
IDEO double one lasted purpose in the
early 2000 Romania got warp speed
internet connection
and also addressed the computer hacking
issue
Larry is happy that he was a student
back then because he had he had freedom
he says that nobody will be able to
duplicate what happened there
II do double one hackers still ruled the
world they are among the best C's admins
and security professionals in Romania
Larry is brilliant he also does
do-it-yourself projects all the time and
there has travelled the world has worked
for different companies vampy says he
won't be vampy anymore because he is
wearing bracelet to strengthen his teeth
so by autumn he won't be bumpy anymore
Stefan pushkar is still a sysadmin and
politécnica University and by a twist of
fate the guy ended up teaching computer
networks in the very ID or double one
the cover engineers are reconnected
after a decade they also work for
startups and companies in Bucharest and
like to mentor the younger generation
telling them that hardware and software
should be connected and some of the
engineers who designed the Cobra
computers in the official factory in
Brussels moved to the US and started
working for Apple some of them were part
of the team that created the iPhone X so
if you happen to use an iPhone X now you
know that it's somehow connected to this
computer Romanian computer from the
ADA's most of my stories
they look like stories about hackers or
computer professionals but actually they
are not there are stories about regular
people like you and me
sometimes people who don't have a lot of
resources but people who have passion
and want to discover the world
and want to do the best with what they
have I would like to remind you that we
have this Romanian brandy I hope you
paid attention to the presentation and
we're going to have a Q&A session
upstairs and one of you could win this
and after the Q&A session maybe we could
play some manic miner on an old Romanian
computer thank you so much for being
here today
you